with Santa manage the boss Ricky Rozay
may 24 self-made will be their stores
and you better keep a lot right here
bootleg Carol comm100 portable a cabin
to come back because huh special guest
in studio right now mr. Rick Ross know
what it is how I'm doing sir no hustler
many feel good to be home hey I'm
sobriety the last night man you still
functional matter you shut down the palm
got it out oh man you know you know it
was no it was a special moment here I
was here I celebrated my birthday in
vegas last year when i was said on jay-z
name was actually on the Billboard an
army I just like you know all my went to
the concert and it was dope just so just
to pull up to the venue you know and
going in and do my thing use it was
accomplished that's what I'm talking I'm
glad I glad you can do bad you can't be
begging to be true what you're saying
man I mean like we get a big star long
time but no you don't ever get too many
bosses you don't know I got love for Las
Vegas mean as a matter of fact it's
rustling grass on the UH the new Maybach
Music deal with Warner Brothers man yeah
yeah sure the Warner Brothers Maybach
Music wale Meek Mill Hill domi by
Lucifer man it's a great situation I've
been riding with pill man for for a
couple years I gotta support his vision
for a long time what uh what what I
guess what brought you the signing it
was a dope MC you know them said I just
throw them down your radar for a while
yeah the most different pitches already
said so we got together and we made a
great situation i mean and i think is
just go bring a lot of light on this
channel homies ready to spit up and we
was in the studio two or three days ago
man one of the verses he kicked
management graves definitely be a
problem yeah the compilation um
self-made dropping one day 24th right
May twenty-fourth man the biggest
compilation no research are we going
back to the error a dopo see ya ruff
rider was doing compilations and you
just love the energy in the records that
that the dudes brought to the table so
May twenty-fourth is going down
self-made
new album for me bak music Warner it's
going to be big I saw on Twitter you
guys were in the studio with drizzy the
other day / I Molly moms man is he going
to be on the compilation when I don't
wear the most definitely you know I'm
saying Drake will be on a compilation
man you know that's the homie soysal
love he embraced in the movement and you
know just feel good to rock out with
your family shut up why you'll see him
be be kicking that talk this means the
air so yeah we finna get back to the
fake you yeah yeah yeah yeah you know
the document i got spirit fills I got
you know that still be on the world
would be documenting this Italian tool
and all no just look for this crazy they
doing study right now man I was just
watching you on vh1 last night the hip
hop honors they've replayed it again
yeah I'm not nothing like that I was
like damn dude up my man he's gonna be
in town to get the concert and not us to
do I can't believe it Rick Ross live
we've got nicer if i was crazy sorority
no I saw the next I saw the record God
forgives I don't when you put down a
hole for a little bit focused on the
compilation or the compilation made 24
and then I'll God forgives I don't come
in after that so you know reprioritizing
was ended and that's what it is Teflon
Don it seem like that kind of just shot
you into a whole nother level in the
game man like you know you're always a
big name in jail but teflon don was that
classic day ya knows it was just so
well-executed album no you know the
records was was dope the streets
embraced it and you know we really got
our hand did that groundwork me really
got out in the streets are really you
really are you know push the bird noise
like whoever would have thought I saw
might be enough of this i just smash you
know i was told over you every book I'm
saying with such a street record and it
was huge you know you know was just
speaking for everybody yeah vegas to LA
to New York City to the south then no
matter where you from it was still about
this struggle is still about the hustle
for everybody who get up your mean II
gotta go get a as an MC man i respect I
respect your skills as an MC like above
all your I mean I don't think anybody
can really people can hand on you for
whatever they want but when it comes to
spitting man oh hell yeah absolutely
know what I'm saying you're definitely
um you know I think one of the top can
do is doing it right now you know
no you can't even hate cuz we live right
and I wanted to ask you your writing
process man because sometimes I be
hearing your verses on my damn like you
know that they're dope but what is your
writing process you write stuff down you
go up top er yeah it depends you know it
depends a lot of times are just all say
things in and Swift my writing in this
blackberry I bring them back up in the
studio sometimes I may just be sitting
there next needle jumped some down but
you know just depend on the vibe of the
record you know being a Maryland okay
now is just an emotion so you know those
kind of records is justified you know I
mean so I just feel good to just you
know on come across man and then just be
able to all work with such great
producers in you have such a great ear
for production man we've seen me in
consequence was just talking about that
you are like one of the illness when it
comes to picking beats oh man in a
beautiful thing about that is all we'll
be making some announcements real soon
look at you know as far as laid-back
music n it up and not very own
production company and really bring in
those sounds right producers you know to
the forefront especially weather like
it's the run it like you made the
runners you know you gave them a name
you know what I'm saying same thing with
Justice League yeah we was able to work
with a lot of dope you know producers
what I was young you know for cooling
trader runners the incredibles yes looga
you know that this goes on we'll shout
out to the Olympics shout out to the
Transformers you know yeah everybody
that we bring it into the fold and we
got some huge announcements to make you
know we're certain select select fuel
producers I shut up to the select few
hey I heard I heard there was a
nine-piece remix coming that's the word
man i heard that might be on that is
that true I mean we go to see what's
under we go to wait around she was so
Kai how's the joint right there I don't
want to trade in my android and get the
iphone ah here i am AIP right now man
rick ross live in studio hot 97 five but
they can't blvd daly slip it under one
or two
an absolutely out of control are you
requested shops 3205 may three four we
will hang out with rig into the few more
minutes do not go to where you are hot
on 75